[ANNOUNCEMENT]
JENDAYI FRAZER: We're going to start a little
early.
I think we have a critical mass here.
There's more tents out there, but we really
do have a full house and we want to make the
most of this opportunity.
So let me start with a, you know, customary
welcome to today's Council on Foreign Relations
meeting, but also the reminder that we would
ask if you could please completely turn off
and not just put on vibrate your cell phones,
your BlackBerrys and all wireless devices,
to avoid interference with the sound system.
As a reminder, this meeting is on the record.
It is being taped, and it will be put up on
the website.
It is with great honor and pleasure that I
introduce our speaker to the Africa Roundtable,
Ms. Obi Ezekwesili, or Obiageli Ezekwesili,
who is a VP for the World Bank's Africa Region
since 2007, in which she oversees 47 countries,
1,600 staff, and in 2010 was responsible for
$11.5 billion in new lending projects in Sub-Saharan
Africa and 1.15 billion U.S. dollars in grants.
Prior to coming to the World Bank, Obi was
the minister of education of the government
of Nigeria from 2006 to 2007.
And prior to that, she was minister of solid
minerals development from 2005, 2006.
She has also been in the private sector at
Deloitte & Touche as an auditor, management
and financial services consultant.
She was a founding director of Transparency
International and the director for their Africa
branch from 1994 to 1999, and chairperson
of the Nigerian Extractive Industries Transparency
Initiative in 2004.
There are many more positions that Obi has
held.
And you can see some of those in the written
bio.
She is a chartered accountant.
She received her master's in international
law and diplomacy from the University of Lagos,
her master's in public policy and administration
from Harvard University at the Kennedy School
of Government where Obi and I met, as well
as her bachelor's degree from the University
of Nigeria.
She will be speaking, having worn many different
hats, so I know that we're going to have an
outstanding dialogue today, working in the
private sector, in the public sector for international
financial institutions and for international
civil society.
And so, Obi, we really look forward to your
remarks and the dialogue following.
Over to you.
>>OBIGELI EZEKWESILI: Thank you.
Is this on?
Yes.
Well, thank you very much, Jendayi.
This is a long way back from 2000.
My famous story with Jendayi was how in 2000
we, having done a course of study called "Crafting
U.S.-African Foreign Policy," hardly did we
realize that that work together was going
to be implemented by you, so to speak.
Because you know, a lot of what we were talking
about concerning Africa, U.S. foreign policy,
ultimately became what you had to use in shaping
your period in the Bush administration.
And I do want to acknowledge the great work
that you did during your time as assistant
secretary for Africa, and for the partnership
that we had.
And it was strong enough and did result in
some tangible good across the continent.
I want to thank you all for the opportunity
of addressing you this afternoon.
And I do want to say that we are in a world
that using the word "precarious" is almost
an understatement considering that we frankly
do not know what this evening would bring
in terms of the uncertainties that we all
have to manage.
Whether they be countries or they be (friends
?) or they be communities or even the individual
citizen, managing uncertainty and risk has
become an important subject of life.
That being the case, when recently the bank
did our economic update and came with the
sense that it is less (cheery ?) than anyone
would hope since the last time that our focus
came out.
It pointed to the fact that we are in waters
that will remain very difficult to manage
for a long time.
However, the prospect of optimism in the light
of all of these is what drives me to the importance
of the conversation around the place of Africa
as a continent within these global uncertainties
that we must manage.
Let us focus for the global economy got revised
downward, and we basically say that we're
going to face slower pace of expansion, 2.5
percent in rate of growth globally.
Europe appears to have entered a recession.
And the euro forecast is seeing to -- leads
to a contraction to about 0.3 percent for
the year 2012.
In the same vein, the forecast for developing
countries, which used to really be the good
news in most of the forecast in the past,
is that it has slowed, and it's also facing
its own serious challenges of managing the
global contraction.
The forecast is that it will be 5.4 percent
and 6 percent in 2012, 2013, respectively.
This is of course down from the 6 percent
and 6.3 percent barely less than a year ago
in our forecasting.
The 2012 annual meeting of the World Economic
Forum picks up on these very precarious contexts
within which global growth is being observed.
And the topic says "the great transformation."
It's amazing how people come up with topics
of this kind at the times of very difficult
scenarios.
And it says "shaping new models" -- the great
transformation, shaping new models.
And part of what I read out of the statement
of -- (inaudible) -- was basically calling
to question some of the models, some of the
things that we've been so used to, some of
the structures and some of the concepts with
which we have worked, and questioning whether
the paradigms that we have known continue
to be relevant to the imagined scenarios that
we're all faced with.
And it basically is saying that there was
need for leadership at different levels around
the world to begin to redefine what the future
could be.
As I read it, it reminded me of something.
I was home recently -- and you know, I come
from Nigeria, and so we've been facing quite
some challenges in Nigeria.
And one of the young people on television
said something about some of the elders that
were part of the conversation.
He said, why do you want to be the voice that
gives the solution to a future that you will
not be part of?
And I thought this is is so morbid!
(Laughter.)
But when that young child said that, it got
me thinking that, truly, we must be careful
how much we assume that we still have the
solutions to what the future will be.
I think that part of the concept of moving
toward the new global reality is going to
be how much of the voice of those to whom
that future belongs to we make as a part of
the conversation.
So as I look around the table, I'm thinking
to myself, we do need to have a Council on
Foreign Relations that will begin to look
at those in their 20s as important contributors
to the imagined world and imagined reality
that we're going to be facing.
The Global Issues Group, which comprises leaders
of the world's multilateral and regional institutions,
put its foot forward by affirming that the
solutions to realizing the objectives for
strengthening growth, employment and quality
of life in every part of the world, and indeed
for resolving severe challenges faced by the
global economy, would lie in economic transformation
that will happen in developing countries -- in
developing countries, meaning that whatever,
however you define "developing countries"
of which Africa occupies a very important
space, working out of the reality that we
confront today is going to very much depend
on how the solution is centered within the
problems that they face.
And so for us, the global economic trend seems
to suggest that the developing world is no
longer the one with the monopoly to risk.
So clearly, the address where risk resides
has gone global.
And to the extent that investment risk, the
new risk reality, has emerged as one that
is ubiquitous, one that is less associated
with just the developing world of particularly
a continent like Africa, the macro trends
that we see and the landscape that we observe
means that for boardrooms across the globe
that are seeking the unbeaten path for capital
flows, it's going to be important how Africa
and the rest of the developing world is considered.
Your topic said Africa is the next frontier.
I believe that -- in Africa, recently I was
taken to task by a very vigorous young one.
You know, this is the era of the young, frankly.
You better prepare yourself anytime you're
speaking to them.
They said, you know, the idea of Sub-Saharan
Africa doesn't appeal to her and we should
stop calling -- saying "Sub-Saharan Africa,"
we should say "Africa South of the Sahara."
And so I stand corrected by my young friend.
I'm sure she's probably listening, so she
knows I took the correction.
It is not a surprise that more and more people
are beginning to see the opportunities on
the continent.
The fact is that as an investment frontier,
Africa's story remains a very complex one.
It is not a "single story," using the word
of my fellow compatriot Chimamanda Adichie,
who cautions against the single-story complex.
Some of the continent has shown clearly that
it is not one to be associated with the stories
on civil wars, military takeover and insurgencies
and genocides and all of the things that defined
the old Africa that some continue to insist
is the only picture of the continent that
they see.
The reality is that there's an aspect of Africa
that has emerged, and within the last decade,
clearly, one that has made giant strides toward
more-open society.
And so the concept of openness and the concept
of democratic traditions have overridden some
of the well-worn -- (inaudible) -- of a continent
that was considered a basket case for its
inability to build the right systems and structures
and institutions that underpinned free elections
and successful economic strategies, and therefore
provided growth and (provide a reduction ?) for
citizens.
Beyond even the progress on the democratic
space with many more elections and transitions
that have happened successfully is also the
fact that the openness has resulted in a better
embrace of the economic imperatives of macroeconomic
stability and the basic trust that the fundamentals
are not any different as far as economic growth
is concerned.
And that if Africa understood and embraced
the tradition of working through market principles
and defining the roles of government and the
roles of the private sector appropriately,
that Africa, paying attention to the key fundamental
issues of economic policy, could grow.
And so we saw in the last decade a continent
that made peace with the embrace of the market
as an important factor for growth.
An eminent business person did say that profit
lies where the gap between perception and
reality is greatest.
He's not alone in that.
I mean, think of it.
The Economist, a magazine that I grew up on,
because I had a dad who was one of their greatest
fans, but I had to go -- I had to dump The
Economist for a while because it woke up one
day and decided that an entire continent could
be called "hopeless continent."
And it did this in 2000, it had that caption
and said "hopeless continent."
Why?
It was mirroring basically that perception
that it was a continent that many assumed
would never find its feet in the global scheme
of things.
Well, you know, there's nothing like a -- (inaudible)
-- to give you a different set of wisdom.
And so within the last decade, as Africa began
to show that it is indeed capable of taking
hold of the key economic concepts and translating
the poor performance that it was associated
with into better performance on the economic
space, we now see that the 2011 edition of
the same Economist points to it and says we
recant of what we said of Africa a decade
ago.
We do recant of it; and therefore, we now
say Africa rising.
Now, Africa rising is a good story, is a good
caption, but it's important to our piecing
together where Africa is rising from and where
it is supposed to be rising to.
In Africa today, we see the brightest possibilities
as being in the fact that you have the continent
driving its economic vision.
The economic vision of the continent has become
one that the continent itself is defining,
which is quite so different from what happened
in the past where there was almost a confusion
as to what the vision of economic development
was supposed to be.
In the interaction that one has with the leadership
and the citizens of the continent, that matter
of taking ownership of an economic vision
is so key, because then it determines that
the level of commitment and investment into
realizing that vision that both the leadership
as well as the citizens are willing to offer.
In the last decade, what we saw was basically
an Africa that made peace with the concept
of macroeconomic stability as being fundamental
for growth.
Now, once that happened, and that's about
taking ownership of the economic vision, you
did not need to tell any leader that the kind
of fiscal recklessness and rascality that
was associated with economic behavior in the
past would undermine the economic vision of
growth and poverty reduction.
They lanced that.
You began to see management of the economy,
of the macroeconomy, both on the fiscal and
on the macro side from the perspective of
guarding that economic reality of the necessity
for macroeconomic stability.
Now, why is that important?
It's important because when the crisis of
2008 commenced around the world, the continent
that kept with macroeconomic stability the
most was Africa.
Africa kept with it while other parts of the
world began to have loser economic policy.
Many of the leaders on the continent held
on tightly to fiscal prudence and to ensuring
that the management of the macroeconomy -- inflation,
interest rate, foreign exchange -- the management
of it was guided seriously by this continent.
And what we see since 2008, even at a time
when they have less fiscal space today than
they had at the outset of the crisis in 2008,
is a continuing to guard that space.
So I make a big thing out of Africa accepting
an economic truth and owning it as being important.
The reason I can say that very, very vigorously
is that I work within an institution which
for many years, many decades was looked on
by most of Africa with suspicion as being
institutions that wants to impose ideas on
Africa.
Well, the World Bank doesn't need to say that
macroeconomic stability is important, to any
leader anymore on the continent.
They finally got that, and they are doing
it themselves.
Some of them are even doing -- holding on
tightly to it more than the expectation that
Bretton Woods institutions want of them.
That's key, because to be able to achieve
the macro stability, the next level becomes
your second-generation reforms, and that's
where the difficulty shows up.
Because what it took -- the great investment
it took to get to the point where African
leaders and policy practitioners understood
the necessity and the fundamental need for
macroeconomic stability and to hold on so
tightly to it with good effect.
Because as I speak, of all the continents,
Africa's rate of growth before the crisis
in 2008 had become an average of 5.7 percent,
sharply declined to 1.9 percent at the height
of the crisis.
But 2010, it's started a trend up back from
1.9 percent and ended at 3.80 percent.
By 2011, we're talking about 4.3 percent.
And by -- it's just continuing to be on the
upward growth.
Our sense is that, excluding South Africa,
the regional average for Africa's growth would
be 5.9 percent, although with South Africa
it ends as 4.9 percent.
Now, that's significant in a world where we're
seeing such low growth levels in the most-advanced
of economies.
So this puts it on the path immediately next
to the Chinas and the Indias.
And that's important to have as a perspective
as we look at Africa's role going forward.
The great story for Africa sometimes is made
to appear as a single story by people who
say, OK, yes, so maybe the growth is because
of the expansion in the commodities market;
and therefore, that's what's driving the growth.
But I want to clearly state that as we decompose
the sources of the growth, what we find is
that only one -- (inaudible) -- can be accounted
for by the commodities story.
The rest of it is actually about macroeconomic
reforms and the investment in the second-generation
reforms that are supposed to spur growth through
better economic policymaking.
This growth story is not enough.
The growth story is not enough because the
growth story is one that excludes quite a
huge population on the continent, that must
benefit from growth.
And that's where the role of the World Bank
and other institutions and partners of Africa
in focusing on how the growth can become stronger
and the growth can become broader, and therefore
growth that can be shared by quite a larger
population of citizens, where 50 percent are
still in the category of the poor, becomes
the next-most-important agenda.
And that's where the issue I alluded to on
structural reforms, the second-generation
forms, becomes key.
And that's where, if you say Africa is the
next frontier for growth, where would the
growth be coming from?
One important source of that growth, besides
the good economic policy, is going to be how
you focus on the right kinds of investments
in sectors where the good policymaking is
happening.
And my proposition is that agriculture and
agribusiness is an important area of focus
for Africa's economic growth.
Agriculture and agribusiness, the value-added
prospects that they hold and the fact that
it is still a continent where more than 70
percent are in this sector.
Whatever Africa does with other sectors of
opportunities, agriculture has to be a key
component of Africa's readiness to embrace
private capital of the magnitude and beyond
what we have seen in its embrace of policies
and the right public investment that opened
up the information and communication technologies
sector.
The telecom sector has been an incredible
success on the continent, but the opportunity
to benefit from growth for the average citizen
on the continent is going to be through what
we do with agriculture.
And so in looking at agriculture, we say that
Africa has one-quarter of he world's -- (inaudible)
-- land.
In fact, 50 percent of the outstanding is
in Africa.
Now, if Africa had the right policies and
the right investments into this sector, Africa
would become part of the solution to global
food demand.
And we believe that the demand for food, which
will reach about $100 billion by, you know,
doubling the level by 2015, doubling the level
that it was in 2000, creates a huge opportunity
for an African green revolution that looks
at appropriate investment in both the agricultural
skills as well as the infrastructure that
would necessitate the kind of growth that
is held up in the dormant sector of agriculture,
or the under-productive.
The productivity of the sector is so critical
for Africa to truly emerge as that next frontier
that the topic seeks to explore.
Sub-Saharan Africa does already have many
success stories in agriculture.
The production of, say, cassava chips in places
like Ghana, or organic coffee in a place like
Tanzania, or cut flowers in Kenya, as well
as agriculture in Malawi, all of these products
are today being exported to European and other
Western countries.
Expanding markets, such as their reproduction
in East Africa, is going to be a formidable
opportunity for Africa as a frontier market.
And the good thing about agriculture is the
fact that it really gets to the heart of poverty
on the continent.
For every one farmer in the coco sector of,
say, Cote d'Ivoire, they are responsible the
health and education of a multiple of 10 people
in that country.
So imagine the impact, the quick impact on
poverty, because access to health, access
to education through improved income of the
farmer means a direct intervention, not waiting
for development aid.
But it's actually about families making the
right kinds of decisions about investing in
their children, and therefore improving Africa's
human capital, which essentially is the most
important article of fate that we must all
subscribe to concerning the continent.
That it is not Africa's extractive industries,
but Africa's population, properly educated,
given the right tools to solve economic problems
themselves, that will take the continent higher
than where it currently stays in the ranking
of nations as far as economic performance
is concerned.
One of the things that we've been watching
closely is the interrelatedness of social
and demographic changes and how all of these
create the domestic engines for growth.
Key among this is, of course, urbanization
and the expanding labor force and the rise
of the middle-class African consumer.
In 1980, just 28 percent of Africans lived
in cities.
Today, 40 percent of the continent's 1 billion
people live in cities, and this is comparable
to what you have in China and in India, in
fact larger than what you have in India.
By 2030, that share is expected to rise to
50 percent.
And Africa's top 18 cities will have a combined
spending power of $1.3 trillion.
At the same time, Africa's labor force is
expanding, in contrast to what is happening
in the rest of the world.
So while the rest of the world is facing aging
populations, Africa is becoming much more
youthful, much more vibrant.
The continent has more than 500 million people
of working age.
By 2040, the number is projected to exceed
1.1 billion, more than in China or India.
And these people are going to be the ones
that lift the GDP of the continent.
But lifting that GDP means that the investment
in the young has to start today.
It's a double-edged sword to have a youthful
population.
It's either we're investing in this youthful
population, converting them to the human capital
that would determine the innovations and the
solutions of the present and the future, or
we would have a situation where they would
become the underbelly of economies that never
go beyond their current performance.
And in fact, they would become sources of
destabilization on the continent.
Disruption would necessarily happen where
the citizens, especially these youthful ones,
do not have the opportunity to express themselves
as economic agents, which is what is encouraged
through the greater openness of the continent
to open economic principles.
Of course, an important theme that we need
to get in mind is that climate change is a
risk that faces Africa.
Even though Africa's contribution to global
warming isn't as significant as you may, which
is 0.2 percent -- .02 percent, the fact is
that the impact of the climate change, climate
variation, weather variation is already huge
on the continent.
Whether it is in what you have followed in
the Sahara region of Africa, or it's in the
coastal erosions or in the (decertification
?) that's happening with such frequency, and
the heat waves and the storms and the floods,
all of our different parts of the continent,
it is clear that agriculture stands a risk,
even though we have a valuable proposition
that leads to that real growth.
Because when you look at the comparative-advantage-embracing
approach for economic policy, and agriculture
is it, then anything that threatens agriculture
fundamentally like climate change becomes
an important element for focus by the African
policymaker.
And so beginning to look at this as something
that practitioners on the continent will pay
attention to is critical.
I do want to say that there are many issues
that we can learn from.
In the improvements that we've seen in investment
flows into Africa, taking the telecom sector
as an example, what we have learned is that
the right public policy preceded the flow
of investment.
Now, with that lesson, it means that outstanding
areas of reform in energy, in transportation,
in agriculture, in health, in basic environment
and sustainable development and all that that
is associated with it, we need a strong focus
on the right sets of policies -- the right
sets of policies, the right sets of legal
and regulatory systems, the right sets of
definition of rules of government as well
as the private sector.
But even more important is an understanding
of how innovation happens.
When the telecom sector and the ICT took off
on the continent, hardly did anyone realize
how a country like Kenya, with its youthful
population, would be the first set of people
that would take this access to information
as an important tool for economic interaction.
And so the (impasse ?), the mobile money today
is associated with the innovation in Kenya.
The good thing is it's an example of how innovation
can be driven within the continent.
Because at the World Bank, we actually support
through the (South-South ?) lending the provision
of the lessons of the (impasse ?) to countries
in Asia.
So Africa is a home for innovation.
What it means is that, as we look at energy
and we look at agriculture, what are the innovations
that could come out of all of this?
But only to the extent that we can see that
interrelatedness between the policy, the necessary
investment on the side of government and the
definition of a clear road for it, as well
as the participation of the citizens in finding
the solutions that are appropriate for them.
The challenges that remain are huge, as I
said.
Less than 25 percent of Africa's population
has access to electricity, compared to 40
percent in other low-income regions.
The consequence is that Africa is less competitive
beyond the factory floor and remains constrained
and unable to take advantage of the 2 percent
increase in growth as well as 40 percent increase
in productivity levels that result from better
infrastructure.
In fact, you know, when you look at the challenge
of energy on the continent, it's such an incredible
obstacle to growth.
And yet, we know that by reforming and structurally
changing the sector and having the right policy
framework and legal systems, that the same
way that the market was drawn to the opportunity
in the telecom sector, so also will the market
be drawn to the opportunity in generation,
in distribution.
And so what are the incentives that would
drive the process of making this sector a
sector that opens up and receives the market
as they come calling?
It's a huge place of opportunity.
Even in the financial sector, still just less
than 30 percent of Africa has access to financial
services.
What does that say for a frontier market?
Access to finance is the life wire of any
economy.
And if there are still serious exclusion of
a huge population, financial exclusion, then
there is an opportunity in that space for
really bringing more people into the economic
activities.
It was Winston Churchill that said that the
pessimist sees difficulty in every opportunity,
while the optimist sees opportunity in every
difficulty.
And so in the Africa rising, Vijay Mahajan
adopted the approach and sees Africa as a
home to more than 900 million consumers richer
than most people think and presenting an opportunity
as big as China and India.
Now, if that is taking a perspective, it shows
that the Council on Foreign Relations is having
the right kind of conversation, because if
you fragmented Africa, you would not see this
big essence of the market and the opportunity
it presents, which is what takes me to the
issue of regional integration, because the
regional integration of the continent is really
one idea whose time is well past.
(What can we talk ?) of regional integration
has been more difficult than expressing the
desirability of it.
And so the kind of attention to the opportunities
for integrating policies and investments and
identifying solutions that can be solved from
the perspective of regional goods is really
germane to any conversation on Africa as a
frontier market.
Markets that are too small are of less significance
than markets that are sizable.
And so in the work that we do with the continent,
whether it's in the integration through infrastructure,
or it's integration through policy harmonization,
or it's integration through institutions and
regulatory systems, what we're pushing toward
is as driven by the leadership of the continent
that it not be so separated from the domestic
policy environment.
The domestic policy environment and this regional
policy environment must find places of convergence.
And the further studies into the political
economy of fostering those linkages is going
to be a key and an important area of focus.
Most of Africa says enough with development
aid, we want trade and we want investment.
And I agree, completely agree.
But there is still a huge agenda for investing
to enable the right business environment on
the continent.
Beyond the reform of the business environment
in the -- (inaudible) -- of investment climate
reforms, if you do not solve the energy crisis
on the continent, the cost of doing business
on the continent remains really prohibitive.
If you do not solve the transportation issues,
if you do not invest and produce the right
variety of skills on the continent, the cost
of labor continues to be -- will be prohibitive.
Then the population is not an advantage, because
side-by-side a population are opportunities
for work that will be taken up by others.
And so all of this means that both development
assistance, trade and investment must all
come together as a package that will support
Africa in emerging into that frontier that
we all agree it must emerge into.
The role of the Diaspora as part of that strategy
for mobilizing as much resources for Africa's
investment as possible is key.
There are some of the countries in Africa
today where the Diaspora flows whenever the
decline become a business for balance-of-payment
crisis.
It's become that important.
And so how the transition that would begin
to happen as you see more of the country -- more
of the development -- more of the countries
providing development assistance to Africa,
as they go through the global economic crisis
and as they try to determine priorities, it's
going to be important that conversations as
to how the Diaspora flows begin to solve as
much more than a simple or mere social protection.
Because today, the value of a lot of the Diaspora
flows is as a social safety net for the Africans
that receive those money.
But it has much more role for development
as we see.
And so some of the conversations on Diaspora
bonds have got to be much more sophisticated
than merely looking at it as an instrument
to mobilize resources.
But to coherently defining the space that
those resources would take in helping to accelerate
and push up growth in particularly the sectors
that are key factors for growth is an idea
that's right on the table.
Our estimate is that remittances are more
than double official aid received by developing
countries, reaching about 325 billion (dollars)
in 2010, of which more than 20 billion (dollars)
flows to Africa.
Now, $20 billion is significant resources
flowing as Diaspora resources.
For this reason, we are focused on work that
reduces the transfer costs of worker remittances
and work that helps to look at them for their
impact on growth and poverty reduction by
unlocking opportunities to channel those remittances
to productive investment rather than mere
consumption.
For investors, what I would always ask is,
do you yet have an Africa strategy?
If Africa is the now and the future, then
no global player will do well by not having
their Africa strategy.
For partners or investors, working with the
continent means understanding the continent.
And so the necessary investment in understanding
the opportunities as well as the challenges
on the continent would go with understanding
the citizens and the voice that they express
about where they see the continent going.
And that takes me to the importance of the
civil society and the voice of the citizens
in Africa.
A lot of what's driving better performance
in some of the countries that we see is that
demand for good governance and accountability
is becoming a pattern of relationship between
those that govern and those that they govern.
And so, how can we consolidate this demand
for good governance by the citizens of the
continent?
How can we as partners, whether in the development
world or in the private sector, encourage
the kind of responsible partnership with the
civil society, with citizens group, with communities
in the kind of way that governance, which
was always the key obstacle to Africa's growth,
can finally be one that gets resolved through
the participation of the three sectors: by
private sector, public sector and the civil
society.
For us at the bank, our focus has been on
the governance agenda and the public sector
as the foundation of everything that we do.
We came to the awakening that even in solving
Africa's energy problem or solving its transportation
problem, ultimately, it would be a governance
and institutions-building issue.
And so working through that process means
that you cannot do the governance agenda with
the citizens.
It's ultimately about the citizens.
And it's a message to those that lead the
continent.
The citizens of the continent are asking for
better governance.
It's not an external agenda.
No one external to Africa can foster good
governance as much as the citizens can.
And that space where the citizens are occupying
now and demanding on the business of greater
transparency and access to information for
results from government means that everyone
of us, including the Council on Foreign Relations,
should really be spending a lot of time trying
to figure out what it is that we can do to
support the voice of the citizens, to strengthen
that voice and that demand for good governance
and for results.
Because it is in so doing that the economic
freedom and the right economic policies will
come together and enable the performance that
readies Africa more and more as that frontier
that no one can ignore.
So thank you very much.
(Applause.)
>>FRAZER: Well, thank you, Obi.
That was really quite fantastic.
You've put a lot of serious substance before
us.
I heard someone outside before we started
say that there's people around the world who
are going to be sad that you're leaving the
World Bank.
And I certainly share that sentiment.
But I have another one in which I'm so happy
you're leaving the World Bank, because a force
with the voice that you have and the ability
that you have, going back to Africa and working
for all that you just stated here, makes me
very confident in Africa's future.
And so I'm very pleased that, in many ways,
you're going to fly free and do your thing.
And we're going to look forward to watching
you over the coming years.
But with that, let me open the session for
question and answers.
We want to invite the audience members to
join in a discussion.
If you have a question, please orient your
name tent vertically so that I can see your
name.
When you are called upon, please state your
name and affiliation, and keep your questions
as concise as possible to allow as many participants
as possible to speak.
And I'm going to take three questions at a
time.
And we have about 15 minutes' worth of time
for the Q&A.
So with that, I'm going to just go right around
the table.
Mr. Robert Hertzberg and then Joel and then
Ambassador Davis.
>>QUESTIONER: My question relates to good
governance.
Your final comments, you indicated this is
fundamentally up to the citizens of Africa.
But you also -- I heard you also call for
help from the Council on Foreign Relations
and the people around the table.
What is the role of outsiders in helping to
foster good governance in Africa?
>>QUESTIONER: Joel Barkan, Center for Strategic
and International Studies.
First, thanks very much for the first point
you made about Africa is not a single story.
It's a very varied one.
My questions are basically two.
You talked about ownership.
And at the bank, one of the mechanisms for
facilitating ownership has been budget support.
And yet, there has been some stepping back
from budget support in a number of countries,
Uganda in particular in recent years.
I'd like you to comment about budget support
as a mechanism.
And secondly, in respect to your point about
macroeconomic stability, there also appears
to be some slippage in parts of the continent
-- again, Uganda, Ethiopia in particular where
inflation is now 40 percent.
>>FRAZER: Ambassador Davis.
>>QUESTIONER: Ruth A. Davis, former ambassador
to the Republic of Benin.
Thank you very much for your insightful, sweeping
remarks.
I wish you would comment a little bit about
the role of women entrepreneurs in this sort
of developing a new frontier, economic frontier.
>>FRAZER: Thank you.
>>EZEKWESILI: OK.
So let me take these ones quickly.
On the role of the outsiders, I think that
there's a lot in terms of partnerships that
are going to be key, and a lot in terms of
the -- in terms of the lessons, the lessons
of performance.
There are many systems that underpin good
governance.
Good governance is not simply anecdotal.
There are important systems and structures
that are going to be necessary.
There's a lot of human capacitation issues
that are involved.
There is a need to underpin good governance
in analysis, in clear definition of what the
intended outcomes are.
And there's a lot that is missing yet in that
conversation, because even though citizens
are finding their voice because of the global
reality that we all face today, that citizens
have more access to information, you have
to ask, what kind of information?
The quality of the information, the analytics
behind the information, means that there is
need to engage.
There are certain groups that have been trying
to do things, say, in the health sector, from
the outside.
Well, don't try doing that thing as an outsider.
I mean, perhaps what you really need to be
doing is finding the voices from within (lose
?) interest, (rely ?) in that sector on providing
them with the kind of critical knowledge that
they require, because their voice has more
legitimacy than your voice.
The legitimacy and the credibility of the
voice of the owners of the development problem
is really an antidote to a lot of the lack
of traction that we have seen on the conversation
on the demand for good governance.
And I -- it's how we now take this and really
turn it into a product of help, of support,
of partnership that really matters as we go
forward.
You talked about ownership and budget support
and working a way -- we actually at the bank,
in the Africa region, I dare say, our budget
support is an important part of our policy
memo in the work with countries, because this
dramatically helps us to get countries to
take charge of the important reforms that
they want to see happen in critical sectors
of the economy.
But you have to be careful that you don't
do budget support in a situation where there
is an entire -- a lack of appetite for change.
A budget support simply becomes a source of
improving resources that are available for
the wrong kinds of priorities -- you don't
want to do that.
I mean, you cannot be so -- (inaudible) -- about
budget support that you ignore what the outcome
you are trying to achieve really would be,
and whether they're being achieved.
We do a lot of rigorous -- we pay rigorous
attention to what change happens as a result
of budget support.
We avoid budget support fatigue where people
begin to think that they are entitled to budget
support as a way of revenue mobilization,
when indeed it should be the incentive for
ensuring that sustainable reforms are undertaken
so that you can exit from budget support as
a country at some point.
You talked about the slippage in some parts
of the -- in some countries on the continent.
Certainly, a lot of them during this next
cycle of the crisis that we've seen, entered
with less buffer, whether policy buffer or
fiscal buffer.
And so it has meant that it's been more challenging.
But just watch the policy actions of the governments.
Unlike in the past, they went toward the path
of least resistance, which would be to ruin
it even further.
But what you see on the part of policymakers
and the leaders is, trying to manage it and
finding support that would enable them, you
know, get back to the place of stability.
So some of the public expenditure measures
that governments are taking are really being
taken to getting this instability, the macro
instability that is setting back into a place
of stability.
Now, for us, we watch it and we look at how
we can support.
So the support through policy, policy notes
that would enable them know the wrong options
not to take, because there are times when
this situation arises, and the next thing
people do is the action that comes to the
mind.
So we're grounding action in evidence.
And so evidence-based policy, orientation
is really taking foothold, building the critical
capacity within both the ministries of finance,
working with our colleagues in the central
banks with the fund is important for the policy
options they take.
And then looking at public expenditure, looking
at the budget and seeing how the instrument
of the budget can be better utilized for dealing
with some of these challenges that they are
coping with.
But a slippage is bound to happen.
But I look at trend.
I don't look at -- you know, I look at trend.
When a slippage happens, what's the trend
in terms of policymaking.
It's mostly positive in most of the countries
that are affected.
For women entrepreneurs, as you know, the
bank has the gender action plan, and gender
is a key part of our work in the Africa region
considering that some 50 percent of the people
on the continent are women.
And our particular area of focus is women
economic empowerment.
And so you've come out of Benin.
You know the typical Benin woman is an entrepreneur
by nature.
Congenitally, they are entrepreneurs.
And so we're focused on what it is for human
capital development.
We're focused on education; girl child education
is key.
You need a basic level of education in order
to unleash your innovative mind.
That's a piece of it.
The other piece of it are the doing-business
environment for women, looking at the kinds
of obstacles that women entrepreneurs must
face, looking at issues involved in business
registration, in access to capital, in basic
recordkeeping, in access to markets.
So we are focused on that, even at the very
country, up to the project level.
So it's a huge agenda for us.
>>QUESTIONER: Hi, Claire Casey from Garten
Rothkopf.
You spoke about both energy and a need for
energy infrastructure development, and climate
change as a major risk.
And I'm just wondering if you could offer
your perspective on how to reconcile those
two or what the appropriate balance is in
low-carbon development given the urgency of
the challenge, the scale of the challenge
and also the higher costs and risks of -- (inaudible).
>>EZEKWESILI: OK.
>>FRAZER: Michael.
>>QUESTIONER: I'm Michael Samuels from Samuels
International Associates.
Thank you very much for sharing your insights
and visions.
But would you also share with us your two
biggest frustrations from your last period
at the World Bank?
(Laughter.)
>>FRAZER: Jonathan.
>>QUESTIONER: Hi.
Jonathan Cahn, I'm with SNR Denton.
I'm afraid Mr. Samuels has preempted my question.
But I would obviously like to hear your response.
I'll have to leave a bit earlier than I wanted
to, but was asked by Ambassador Bob Gelbard
to give you his regard.
>>EZEKWESILI: Thank you.
>>FRAZER: And then we have eight more minutes,
so we'll finish this round and then we'll
take the last three.
>>EZEKWESILI: OK.
So the climate change and development, I don't
think there has to be a trade-off.
I really think that it is how much we look
at development solutions from an integrated
perspective.
Because as I just said, agriculture is important
for the continent, and there you see that
climate change, with the (floats ?), with
the decertification, with the coastal erosion,
will affect climate change.
So climate-smart agriculture means that you're
going to be thinking of agriculture through
the lens of the risks that are inherent in
Africa not having a good program for managing
the climate change issue.
When you look at Africa's opportunities for
hydropower, it's huge.
Only 10 percent of it is being utilized at
the moment.
Now, what are the drawbacks to unleashing
that opportunity?
That has to be part of the global conversation
as far as Africa's role in helping manage
the global climate change agenda is concerned.
So that way becomes a win-win and not a conversation
that -- (inaudible) -- of Africa's development
for better climate environment.
Otherwise, if you enter that conversation
that way, then you would have people who would
simply say, well, Africa did not contribute
to the global warming.
It's such insignificant contribution; and
therefore, it ought not to just be called
into any kind of arrangements that would -- (inaudible)
-- stem the tide.
But that would be not an intelligent response
to a problem that it is already having to
adapt to.
So I hope that answers your question.
>>QUESTIONER: I think so, yeah.
(Laughter.)
>>EZEKWESILI: Go ahead, ask a follow up.
You seem to --
>>QUESTIONER: Well, I guess one of the most-controversial
projects in the World Bank in recent years
has been a coal plant that arguably was necessary
for feeding industry that's growing.
Those choices are being made every day.
And I was just wondering your perspective
on the path forward.
>>EZEKWESILI: Well, you would see that even
in understanding the role that fossil plays
in energy development and in energy, and therefore
for development, there is a clear understanding
that when you're dealing with low-income,
poor countries that are only just needing
energy in order to start the process of growth,
that you've got to look at it slightly differently
from how you look at it when economies that
have had history of growth for so many decades
continue to behave in an irresponsible manner.
They are two different conversations.
And so reconciling those views in a way that
you recognize Africa's own disadvantage and
yet Africa's own opportunities.
If you took some of the countries where you
have coal in Africa, you would find that there
are countries that have mostly that as the
source of energy.
That is the most they have in terms of natural
resources.
So you take a country like Botswana, a country
like Botswana, it is really -- and yet it
is a country that says we recognize the risks
of climate change; therefore, we will invest
ourselves in looking at renewable options.
That requires significant investment.
As all of that conversation is going on, is
being able to balancing the conversation on
climate change and development as an integrated
solution to the growth of these economies
and the tackling of poverty that would enable
the conversation of a (divisive ?) and a conversation
that requires immediate trade-offs of the
two agenda of development and climate change.
Right?
OK.
And then there was a question as to my two
biggest frustration.
What if it is only one?
(Laughter.)
I think that the -- actually, now that you
ask me, I was thinking as what -- I think,
why don't I start with my greatest joy?
My source of my greatest joy is to see what
is going on on the continent by virtue of
the participation of the citizens in the development
process.
There is no continent that could ever have
developed without the full engagement of the
citizens in the process.
For many decades, it was difficult to get
that level of involvement that I see today
on the continent.
And I have been to most of our client countries,
and my interaction with the citizens always
has been the high point of my, you know, talking
with the presidents and the cabinet is not
even half as exciting as when I am sitting
in a room like this and there are market women,
you know, that are in that meeting, there
are civil society young activists, there is
a private sector entrepreneur trying to make
an inroad into the market space and facing
the obstacles and the constraints.
And in that conversation, the energy that
you see, it is really a source of optimism.
It can do -- it's basically a spirit that
says take the obstacles to our growth away
and you would see us grow.
Now, that is so really wonderful, because
it then helps me shape my conversation with
the policymakers, because in discussing with
the policymakers and reporting that I met
with citizens who know the solutions to their
problems, they are just asking you to get
out of their way, get off their path.
Take the obstacles that you put on their path
away from them and they can find solutions
to their problems.
Many of the citizens are actually not asking
for handouts.
It is so amazing.
They don't need your handout.
They just need the environment to unleash
their creativity, their ideas and their solutions.
That has been a very, very, very, very good
thing that I have benefited in this job.
Now, frustration would have to be -- what
if I don't have any frustration?
(Laughter.)
I am really trying hard to think, because
I am an incurable optimist, right?
So, you know, the -- I am an inpatient optimist.
Ah, maybe that is my frustration!
Yes, it is not happening as fast as I would
like to see it happen.
I mean, I believe that since we know that
Africa must attain 7 percent economic growth
rate per annum on a sustained basis in order
to make a serious dent on the poverty levels.
Right now in the last decade, poverty has
declined by 1 percentage point every year.
I want to see it decline by 5 percentage point
every year.
But what that would require it must see investment.
The investment, public investment and private
investment, that you would need in order to
attain that is so huge, that when I look at
the development space, I don't see it yet.
That has to be a major frustration.
A major frustration is knowing that Africa
needs to raise an additional $48 billion,
less the about 11 billion (dollars) that we
believe can be saved and the 17 billion (dollars)
that we believe can come through better efficiencies
and policies and investment for infrastructure
development.
And looking at the space, looking at the flows,
it is not happening fast enough.
Maybe some of you here can have the solution
to it, but that huge sum that you need in
order to add many (bouts ?) of growth to the
existing growth and take it to 7 percent is
a source of immense frustration for me.
How, where do we find the flows, the flows
that will take care of the infrastructure
problem?
The other frustration, but which I hope will
be overcome, is when people, when the leadership,
those amongst African leadership that still
haven't understood that Africa's great opportunity
is actually the people, not the copper, not
the oil, not the gold, those leaders that
are still caught in this binge for extractives
is a major source of frustration and great
concern for me.
Because an elite class that has not understood
yet what the citizens are saying, which is
that they want education, they want investment
in the things that make them very productive
and competitive.
Moving that agenda would mean that the good-governance
demand would force the leaders to focus on
the things that translate the rents from the
extractive industries into investments in
health, in education, and in important things
that would enable them grow a drive in human
capital base, because it is the knowledge
of the citizens that would really grow Africa
in this next cycle of growth that we are talking
about.
>>FRAZER: I think we have actually heard what
Obi is going to be doing next.
We have heard this over and over.
I think we know.
We have run over time.
I am going to allow the last three to ask
your question, make your statement, but I
would also, you know, maybe suggest that,
Obi, if you can't answer it really quickly
--
>>EZEKWESILI: Sure.
>>FRAZER: -- that you take it outside the
hall so that we can stay -- we are just over
now, and I don't want to go too far over.
So Whitney.
>>QUESTIONER: Thank you, Jendayi.
Thank you, Obi, for a very fulsome conversation.
My question goes to your first comment about
Africa taking ownership for its own economic
policy in vision, and nowhere has it been
more evident recently than in Nigeria and
removal of the oil subsidy.
And we saw very bold economic move, but a
very equally strong public backlash from civil
society.
And I am just interested in your comments
on what the government got wrong and what
the government may have, you know, done right
in that context.
>>EZEKWESILI: It is simple: pace and sequencing.
Pace and sequencing, yes.
>>FRAZER: And concise.
(Chuckles.)
>>QUESTIONER: Yeah, Madame Obi, many respects.
First of all, I want to say many respects.
You have transformed the World Bank and how
many of us relate to the World Bank.
Before we used to be out there throwing eggs
at the bank and now we are inside dialoguing
on important issues, so I want to congratulate
you on that.
My question has to do with agriculture.
And China is -- they are big time now.
Middle East countries are buying up land in
Senegal and Mali, and some of us are wondering
whether or not the future of Africa is being
mortgaged.
Now, you came up with this document, what
is Africa's future and the World Bank support
to it, which is the strategy document before
the bank.
Many of us are concerned that, as you leave,
as you make your departure, the World Bank
may revert back to some of its old ways.
What assurances do we have that the World
Bank will continue along the path that you
have outlined?
>>FRAZER: Yes.
>>QUESTIONER: I would love to hear a little
bit -- my name is David Apgar, I am actually
a consultant with the World Bank.
I would love to hear a little bit about the
vision for innovation and agriculture that
you have.
I mean, this sector is so exciting because
it is immune from two of the four classic
traps that Paul Collier talked about, the
resource trap and the governance trap.
And the two that you have been so involved
with personally yourself.
But it is not going to -- the innovation is
not going to work the way it does in technology
or in sectors that we have seen in Europe
and the U.S., it may be more exciting, but
it is going to be a very different model.
It is not going to be one or two little companies
that suddenly become huge.
I would love to hear a little bit of your
detailed vision for that.
>>EZEKWESILI: Well, you know, I mean, I think
that our agriculture team is quite seized
on these issues of how to first start the
innovation, and that is why in recent times
we have invested on a regional basis on research
and development.
So one of our regional integration projects
is the productivity, agricultural productivity
project: East Africa, West Africa, Central
Africa, and Southern Africa.
Within that project, what we're basically
trying to do is working with the researchers
and the researchers within the continent and
outside of the continent to finding these
new ideas that will really make the agriculture
sector a transformational one and not just
at the top level, but also in terms of organizing
the ideas of the rural farmers and the way
that they have overcome some of the challenges.
And so how do we enhance their productivity
through seeds, new ideas for seeds, ideas
for access to -- (inaudible) -- and new sources
of technology and the integration into the
market.
So it is quite a huge agenda, and I hope that
that is something you can look up on our website
because we do -- we're paying serious attention
to the research and development needs for
that sector, for its transformation.
The question on the -- on agriculture, in
terms of what is called the land acquisition
by outsiders, we have worked with other partners
on something called the code for responsible
agriculture investment.
And this code basically lays out some principles
on the business of which government needs
to be looking at its conversation on land.
And we look at it as being a conversation
that must involve the voice of its citizens.
The reason is that you need a good synergy
between the small, rural farmers and the large
investment.
Just the small, rural farmers would not cut
it.
The large investments ignoring the small,
rural farmers would be a catastrophe.
Therefore, you need a forum and a framework
and systems that are well designed to enable
the necessary conversation between small,
rural farmers and big investors in agriculture.
In a place like Zambia, we have a program
that includes -- that involves outgrower farmers
(scheme ?), and the outgrower farmers are
gaining opportunities to technologies -- exactly
the kind of question -- technologies and access
to imports and access to infrastructure and
even access markets in ways that they were
not in the past.
So how do we take advantage of the opportunities
while reducing, understanding the risks and
mitigating those risks because there are risks?
And then there are risks that pertain directly
to the farmer.
But then there are also governance risks that
are associated with how land deals are made.
So the transparency principles within the
code of responsible investment would help
countries to determine how to ensure that
it is a participatory process and not one
that lends itself to elite rent capture that
we have seen in the extractive industries.
And then I think finally on Africa's strategy,
the strategy is so well -- is so -- is owned
by many.
The strategy wasn't a World Bank strategy.
It is a strategy that all the spectrum of
partners on the continent and outside of the
continent were part of.
We simply coordinated the emergence of that
strategy.
And my sense is that all of the partners that
supported the strategy, particularly our client
citizens, are going to be the owners of this
strategy going forward, and that they are
going to be demanding for the results that
has been promised in that strategy.
And our implementation plan that accompanies
the strategy is already targeted toward ensuring
that, but thanks for the compliment.
Thank you very much.
>>FRAZER: Thank you.